for a long time information on the
Breaking Bad movie was practically as
elusive as Walt and Jesse themselves now
we've gathered every last shard of
information we could get our hands on
while we wait for our Kamino to finish
cooking and a finely crystallized on our
screens after months spent referring to
the Breaking Bad film using the semi
secret codename cream prior Netflix
finally revealed the movie's actual name
in August of 2019 the film will be
called El Camino a Breaking Bad movie
and we'll hit Netflix on October 11th
2019 eventually El Camino will also
report on the air on AMC Breaking Bad's
home network but no date has been
announced yet for the film's cable debut
until Netflix announced the October
release date file camino very little was
known about the movie although Bob
Odenkirk implied that filming had
already been completed when he talked to
The Hollywood Reporter promoting the
upcoming fifth season of the Breaking
Bad spinoff better call Saul on which
Odenkirk stars when asked if the film
was in fact happening Odenkirk replied I
find it hard to believe you don't know
it was shots they did it you know what I
mean
that was that a secret but it is they've
done an amazing job of keeping it a
secret
if secrecy was the goal and Netflix in
the Breaking Bad team definitely
succeeded
Mia days after Odenkirk gave his
interview exciting fans with the
possibility that filming might already
be completed Netflix announced a release
date less than two months away
after months of uncertainty about
whether our movie was even happening the
Breaking Bad film was practically on our
doorstep and we hadn't even realized it
was coming
although Aaron Paul spent the better
part of a year playing his cards
extremely close to his chest numerous
sources speculated early on that hippy
reprising his role as Jesse in the
eventual Breaking Bad film and that the
film would revolve around him now those
suspicions are confirmed Breaking Bad
saw Jesse evolve from a high school
dropout who taught Walter to deal drugs
into the heart and soul of the show
holding fast to the conscience and
morality that Walt slowly and
methodically stripped away as Walt
became more ruthless Jesse seemed to
balance him by becoming increasingly
more sympathetic the final season of
Breaking Bad led to Jesse getting
kidnapped by a gang of neo-nazis and
forced to cook crystal meth for them
until well ultimately came to his rescue
in the finale the last we saw of Jesse
he was driving away from the neo-nazis
meth lab in a stolen car laughing in
relief at the endless possibilities
granted to him by his long-awaited
freedom
despite being the star of the series
gets unsurprising that Walter White may
not play a role in the movie due to his
death in the series finale he's hit by a
stray bullet when he initiates his plan
to mow down on the Oh Nazis that have
captured Jesse and the bleeds Alton a
meth lab still it's hard to imagine any
version of Breaking Bad without crime
stone who was the indisputable star of
the series and brought one of the most
memorable TV characters of the 21st
century to life in Walter White this is
not myth while it appears as though El
Camino will take place after Walt's
death Cranston has said that if asked to
return he would most definitely do it he
told the Dan Patrick show in November
2018 I don't know if there's an
appearance flashbacks flash-forward but
I'm excited about it because it's
Breaking Bad and it was the greatest
professional period of my life and I
can't wait to see all those people again
even if I just come by to visit it's
hard to imagine how a flash-forward
could allow Cranston to come back but a
flashback or even a dream or
hallucination could it be a reasonable
way four bolts make an appearance in the
film even if he's not the star whatever
the method we help al Camino finds a way
to work Walt in even if it is just for a
single scene although Bob Odenkirk seems
to be more in the loop that most people
regarding El Camino he still speaks
about the film as though it's simply
something he's heard about and that's
something he's worked on speaking to The
Hollywood Reporter Odenkirk said I've
heard so many different things about it
but I am excited about the Breaking Bad
movie I can't wait to see it
of course as any Breaking Bad fan could
tell you no one is better at selling a
leiden Odenkirk who plays a slippery
lawyer Saul Goodman or Jimmy McGill
right before he changed his name on both
the original series and the spin-off
better call Saul he was like Houdini
seriously when the going gets tough you
don't want a criminal lawyer
alright you want a criminal lawyer or
I'm saying if he was trying to throw us
off the scent and he actually is in El
Camino would probably never even suspect
the lion to his face suddenly showed up
on our TV screens so well right now
we're willing to take Odenkirk at his
word that is merely eagerly awaiting El
Camino as a fan it's just like the rest
of us we also wouldn't be too surprised
if you had a supporting role after all
joke's on me
haha simple as that we last saw Jesse
Pinkman driving off into the night after
world freedom from his abductors at the
end of Felina
Jesse never gave any indication about
where he might have been headed but
according to the log line of El Camino
we're about to find out
Netflix promises us in the wake of his
dramatic escape from captivity Jesse
must come to terms with his past in
order to forge some kind of future this
seems to indicate that El Camino
presumably titled after the type of card
Jesse drives in the final scene is about
more than just Jesse's physical journey
away from his kidnappers and will
address his emotional one as well the
part about coming to terms with his past
almost definitely refers to the
repercussions of Jesse's illegal actions
with Walt's in the final season
Jesse agreed to cooperate with DEA agent
Hank to incriminate Walt's in exchange
for leniency for himself
however Hank is murdered before that
deal can ever be finalized making Jesse
a fugitive by the conclusion of the
series Jesse may also have to wrestle
with some personal demons such as the
deaths of his ex-girlfriend's Jane and
Andrea who both died because of their
involvement with Jesse perhaps one way
Jesse will deal with the consequences of
his actions will be by going to check on
Andrea's orphaned son Brock and making
sure he is all right
even before the logline of El Camino was
revealed Breaking Bad fans already had
reason to suspect that any potential
film would have to take place after the
finale of the series not only were
rumors already swirling around the
possibility but Jesse centric film but
there's simply no other time in the
Breaking Bad narrative where a
feature-length story might fit walton
jesse meat in the pilot of the series
before that jesse is a small-time drug
dealer and walters a high school
chemistry teacher hardly the stuff
movies are made from it is fascinating
really
after that's the tale of Breaking Bad
was so tightly woven but it didn't seem
possible that there were another two
minutes of relevant story that we didn't
see play out during the course of the
series let alone two hours there was
even an entire episode dedicated to
getting a fly out of their lab we saw
everything
[Music]
Cranston confirmed the post finale
timeframe in an interview with ET where
he said he's still dead in the film and
the official blog line also indicates El
Camino will be picking up right where
the finale left off however if it's been
a while since you've watched Breaking
Bad and you're worried you won't
remember enough to understand El Camino
Aaron Paula suggested you re watch only
one scene to prepare yourself for the
film
Jesse's heartbreaking monologue from
season 3 gets issues ready because if
that scene is any indication of what El
Camino will be like ouch in the process
of announcing the name and premiere date
of El Camino Netflix also dropped a
teaser trailer if it's been a while
since you've watched Breaking Bad you
may not recognize the character at the
center of the teaser but he's someone
who's been around since a very first
season of the show in the short clip
which is set in a police station we hear
a man telling a roomful of officers he
doesn't have any idea where he is or
where he is headed the camera then
pivots around to reveal the speaker
skinny Pete skinny Pete was introduced
in season 1 of Breaking Bad as of I'm
responsible for introducing Jesse to
drug kingpin Tuco Salamanca skinny Pete
later deals Krystal for Jesse Sobers up
relapses and ultimately helps Walt seek
revenge against his former business
partner now it seems as though that DEA
may think that skinny Pete is the key to
locating Jesse but despite their rocky
relationship skinny Pete shows no sign
of turning on his friend know what to
tell you
no way I'm helping you people could
Jesse Pinkman back inside a cage
breaking bad would never have become the
critical and cultural smash if it was
without the vision of Vince Gilligan who
not only created the show but was
responsible for penning some of its most
memorable episodes including box cutter
face-off and the series finale Felina
back when the news first broke that a
feature-length follow-up may be in the
works
fans were relieved to hear that it would
once again have Gilligan at the helm
well Gilligan did not write or direct
every episode of Breaking Bad it looks
as though he'll be doing both duties for
El Camino this won't be the first time
Gilligan has ventured back into the
story of Jesse and Walter since the show
wrapped up in 2013 he is also the
creator of the ongoing spin-off series
better call Sol which premiered two
years after the conclusion of Breaking
Bad after being immersed in this world
for more than a decade there's no one
better than Gilligan to bring Jesse and
the tattered remains of Walt's once
great meth Empire back onto our screens
on the heels of the Breaking Bad finale
Gilligan told GQ his theory about what
happens to Jesse after the events of
Felina he said my personal feeling is
that he got away but the most likely
thing as negative vs. sounds is that
they're going to find this kids
fingerprints all over the slab and
they're going to find him within a day
or a week or a month and he's still
going to be on the hook for the murder
of two federal agents but yeah even
though that's the most likely outcome
the way I see it is that he got away and
got to Alaska changed his name and had a
new life you want that for the kid he
deserves it the murders Gilligan is
talking about a Walt brother-in-law Hank
Schrader and his partner Steven Gomez
who were both killed in the final few
episodes of Breaking Bad of course Jesse
didn't commit either murder pancan Jaime
were killed in a shootout with a
neo-nazis Walt hired to kill Jesse when
he thought Jesse was stealing the money
he'd buried in the desert but the DEA
has no way of knowing that
assuming Gilligan hasn't changed his
mind in the years since Breaking Bad
ended it sounds like we can hopefully
look forward to a happy ending
hopefully the only other options are
that Jesse dies or he winds up in a drab
prison cell being watched by ranks of
faceless guards for the rest of his life
all four murders he didn't commit
that sounds pretty um what's the word
we're looking for here sounds kind of
Kafka ask
ah totally Kafkaesque check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos but your favorite
shows are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and to the bail so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]